こんにちははじめ社長ですもうご存知の方も多いと思うんですけども私始めた超東京
2020オリンピックを応援する cm コカコーラに任命されました
で僕の他にもいろんなユーチューバーさあが任命されているので
東京2020オリンピックを盛り上げるために様々な活動に参加していきますのでぜひ
活躍に骨活躍って言ったら地万博活動にご注目ください今日何していくかと言いますと
オリンピックの種目にもある
q をやっていこうと思いますつだけで今日はスペシャルゲスト
お呼びしておりますモードプロ卓球選手の4つをとさんねーどうぞごです
四元さんは元プロなんですかそうですね
ウン十年愛は設計まずですかってことは強いんですか
いやそんなんでもねパラまあですまあまあまあまあはい
てみてくださいった
違いです a f
またさすが元プロということもあって強いと思うんで普通にやったらとで負けると思う
んですよ
なんとかして勝てないだと思いますでちょっといろいろ準備してみたんでぜひ体験して
いただけると嬉しいですっ
はい行きよろしかっ根拠はなんとかして元プロのやつものさんに勝てるように頑張って
行きたいと思いますそしてさらに今日はですね負けっというか
同じチーム加工等のメンバーの方が来ております
道
清い意識ぽいよりする冬木で愛知へ行くコーラのメンバーのスーパーウォールバーグ
ねー
動きが俊敏
そんなスーパーオーナー baroa されながらも今日は
発揮していこうと思います
駒沢ですね一者
ふうに戦ってみましょうこれでボケが勝ってしまうこともありますので
ちょっと重い
雛見るために1回ちょっとやってみましょう本気でプレイします動いていますそれ
にとっての終わりにしましょうはいよろしくお願いします
はい
まあそうだことからです
ていました
ます
んですが
景色は良い母立付さんかっ
追い詰められましたなんかど旦那に行くよとか始めた彼等から決定しまったよ
いきます
じゃーん
[音楽]
さあ
と言うよとさんの勝ちデー
ハイチュウ許し2てっても勝てないということが分かりました次は4人で買ってる
果たして4人で元プロに振り抜くかどうかやっていきましょう
じゃあはい
いません
ざあなさん
キタージャイ t 4 rar
[拍手]
少なくない
par
[拍手]
色々あるわけで
[音楽]
dare
ません
[拍手]
医学
1位
パワー
逆に登ってどっちを使っていた
ええええええ
dee
ここまでは惨敗してしまいましたがこれは結構買ってるんじゃないかなという作成が
あります初台の町長曲線 pou dou dou じゃないかと思っております風
おりじゃあ
[拍手]
car
[音楽]
ana
car
wh
ああああああ
第2ここからです勝負は追い風でめっちゃ取りに行ってもらってるつを申し訳ないです
すごい鳥居がせて遅い
[音楽]
こう言っていてきましたイェイ
me
ありがとうございやせました違いに置い壁が強いわけではないんで勝てなかったらどこ
やら買ってるんや
うん
おいクズ使っても勝てないとなるともうほぼ将棋がないのですが最後は運に任せ
ましょう
こちら象兄弟に卓球でございます3つ元店主はプロなので卓球のあの大きさに慣れてる
と思うんですよ客に慣れてる分こういう大きなフィールドで戦うといつもの感覚が狂っ
て僕に勝機があるのではない
からという読みでございますこれならた分割
[拍手]
goo
[音楽]
夫がやってみたかんちょっと何か届かなそうだったのでボールとラケットを交えて戦い
たいと思います
もっとプールなんであのサイズにしかなれてないと思うバスます私に商機がある
これはでそうですね
あああああ
ああああああ
[拍手]
ああ
持った
ございます
持っていた
[音楽]
ん
はぁ
ああああああいいいいん
[音楽]
ああ
ああああああ
加工はいお疲れさまで舌セダンですよ
はやなぁ
強かったです横畠氏本当にもどんな姑息な手を使っても勝てなかったので本当にも
強かった今日は本当にありがとうございましたございました
そしてですね今回審判を手伝ってくれたこちらのスーパーポーラベア君チームをコカ
コーラの公式の youtube チャンネルがありましてそちらでバリバリ活躍して
おります
なんかもうちょっと見たんですけど癒着賛同しん
いいんですよねー
自転車とかめっちゃ塗りこなしたりしてるんでぜひ皆さん今後のスーパーポラベルの
活躍にもご注目ください
いうわけでチーム9コーラのツイッターインスターグラム youtube チャンネル
もありますのでそちらもぜひチェックしてみてください
詳しい情報は動画概要欄にありますで季節をチェックしてみてください
だけで今後も中国ゴールの稼いでご注意
僕くださいん
[音楽]
me
バッハ